One of the occupational hazards of doing a
show like this is that my friends, my family,
people who come up to me at the grocery store
or at IKEA, and pretty much everyone I encounter
wants to talk politics with me, in one fashion
or another.
Fortunately, I love talking politics and talking
to people about politics, so I'm usually happy
to engage with people even when I'm picking
out an ice cream or or testing out the Kivik
couch, which is surprisingly comfortable and
easy to put together.
One thing that I've really noticed in our
current political climate is people are having
a harder time tuning politics, even briefly,
to talk about other things.
This is somewhat anecdotal in my case particularly,
but I'd bet it's happening in your life, too.
Suddenly, it seems like every conversation
is political, every discussion somehow gets
back to Trump, and yes, your aunt knows exactly
how to solve America's health care issue,
even though she can't figure out how to sync
her iPad.
On face value, none of this is a problem.
I love people who were largely apolitical
are becoming more engaged.
People are not only talking talking about
politics, but in many cases reevaluating what
their beliefs are because of the upside down
world that we will in right now.
While everything may seem crazy right now,
I really do believe this time we're in right
now is a rare, special moment when so many
people are all doing the same introspection
about their beliefs all at the same time.
Whether this will lead to more or less freedom,
tolerance, or peace all remains to be seen.
But without question we're in some pretty
fertile ground for change right now.
And by change I mean real societal change,
not just hope and change.
One problem I do see attached to all this
opportunity for change and reevaluation is
that people are becoming consumed by politics
in a way which doesn't strike me as particularly
healthy for a human's mental health, or for
our society's at large.
It's one of the reasons I'm a small government
guy.
I want a government small enough that we don't
have to talk about it that much because it
doesn't have the power to do too much, good
or bad, to our lives.
There's a built in trade off there...small
government can only do so much, the rest is
up to the people.
So if you want government to do everything,
you really can't complain when it does all
sorts of things you don't like.
Well, actually of course you can complain
about it, at least until that big government
takes your right away to do just that.
So my message to you this week is: let's keep
talking about all of these issues, let's keep
staying engaging and trying to change things
for the better, but at the same time let's
not let it consume us to the point where it
changes who we are.
Social media can be an awful catalyst to the
endless focus on politics, which is why I've
been trying to take the weekends off and focus
on the world that exists in front of my face
instead of the one that exists in 140 characters.
When you are online though, try to find some
nuance between Trump Derangement Syndrome
and Nazi Frog obsession.
Most people are good and want pretty much
the same things that you do, so let's keep
growing that new center.
And as long as your here right now, we're
once again partnering up with Learn Liberty
this week and we've got author and director
of the philosophy, politics and economics
department at Duke University, Dr. Mike Munger.
We're gonna talk politics, philosophy, economics
and more.
Watch and learn, unless it's the weekend,
in which case I'll give you the day off.